let's keep talking to people because i
don't know there are people who want to
talk and it seems like
it's a great thing
let's go to guillaume from montreal uh
guillaume i had a beautiful time there
last week
oh hi david uh well glad to hear you had
a beautiful beautiful time
uh you know what i was thinking when you
came over i mean i i did not go out all
that much i was pretty much uh secluded
at home it was insanely hot actually and
you know what i told the story uh or i'm
going to tell the story on today's bonus
show i was recognized on the street more
in montreal than anywhere else that i
have ever been i was only there six days
and 12 people came up to me to say they
watched the show
nice nice i mean to be fair most of us
use your show the young turks and david
pakman
not david pacman uh fair and cousins my
bad okay
yeah as a great way to stay informed on
what's happening all the way over there
beautiful
country usa
that's fantastic what was on your mind
today
uh well first and foremost uh just
pointing out that when i when we talked
last time my friends
really liked your idea of uh
trying to tackle the campaign finance as
a whole constitutional amendment good
and my actual big question right now is
a lot more
static it's a lot less hypothetical it's
a question of what do you feel about
calling the current era of politics
worldwide not just in the u.s
an era of um
uh what could i say um
i'm looking for the word here
um
not oh yeah there you go there we go
glory politics so it's all about getting
your name on something it's all about
getting your name to be recognized as
the name that did something good
i don't think that that's unique to this
era i mean for me there are other things
that strike me as unique to this era
including
the high percentage of people engaged in
politics who quite literally have no
idea what's going on and understand
nothing about anything like the fact
that that's a movement and it's a
movement that has pride we don't know a
damn thing about anything and we vote
and you've got to deal with us haha
that seems much more unique to this era
you know the the glory politics stuff if
we want bridges and and all these
different things named after us i feel
like that's been going on
at least since the 50s in the united
states i get what you get what you're
getting at but i'm more thinking about
before it's been built i want my name on
it
i mean we all know that obamacare was
essentially
dubbed obamacare
after it was passed because it was more
convenient than saying an affordable
care act every single time you wanted to
say it
yeah i mean listen i i don't think
you're wrong that this exists it doesn't
strike me as the most notable thing
about the era i'll put it that way
no that's that's perfectly fine yeah on
that lovely note have a great day and
thank you for taking my call guillaume
real quick are you a saint viator bagel
guy or a fairmont bagel guy
um
that's a great question
uh
i'll have to say signed via tour wow
that's a big declaration from you
it's mostly because every single time i
have a bagel that's the most
available to me where i am oh okay so
it's a convenience thing
and
i've never had a single problem with it
so it's a recognizable brand for me it's
a it's a literal
i know this is good enough for me i
don't need to go test further unless
that's unavailable hey if it ain't broke
don't fix it i like that guillaume
i mean don't get me wrong if you if you
serve me any other bagel i'll take it
and probably enjoy it just as much as as
long as it's a decent quality just don't
get
don't get me to try and choose another
than that one i'm with you all right my
friend thank you for the call
thank you and have a great day all right
there's guillaume from montreal